ce qui a changé dans votre façon de
faire l'amour chérie
expérience
bonsoir merci de cet accueil faut rester
assis merci beaucoup c'est très aimable
Laurent n'a pas été accueilli comme ça
c'est vrai
nous en avons un peu marre c'est la fin
de semaine
parce que l'avant avant-dernière c'est
une émission comme une autre la dernière
c'est la dernière mais l'avant
j'ai mal tombé tu es tombé sur
l'avant-dernière
Thierry c'est une corvée pour vous de
faire de la promo télé comme ça non une
corvée je dirais pas jusque là mais
c'est pas mon métier mon métier c'est
pas d'aller vendre ma salade
de faire au mieux pour interpréter ce
qu'on me demande bon donc bah
quelquefois c'est c'est ouais ça c'est
plus dur tu vois ce que je veux dire
vous êtes obligé par contre à le faire
non non vous le faites vraiment pour
pour aider le film quoi on le fait oui
quand on aime le film et quand oui alors
j'ai vu le film j'ai vu le film ça
s'appelle kipper gagne de Laurent
benegui avec Elsa gilberstein Maurice
Bénichou et vous évidemment alors ça
doit être quand l'animateur a pas vu le
film vous le sentez vous le sentez à
quoi
aux vagues de questions
racontez-nous Thierry Lhermitte c'était
intrigue qui est passionnante
là vous dites le mec a pas vu le film
quoi
sexy dans le film vraiment j'ai jamais
vu comme ça ohlala c'est vous qui lui
faites cet effet non c'est bien possible
elle est belle à poil elle est très
belle elle est même un peu dans match
d'aujourd'hui
elle connaît le métier de son mari alors
on apprend bientôt que Elsa Gilbert
Stein c'est si belles filles et
capitaine des renseignements généraux et
directrice de la brigade des jeux et lui
c'est à dire vous vous êtes un requin
des tapis verts alors la c'est le
tricheur vive une liaison secrète en
fait depuis plusieurs années et c'est là
qu'un obscur professeur de mathématiques
gagne deux fois de suite au loto voilà
alors le log line du film ça veut dire
quoi c'est la phrase qui écrit sur la
fiche d'accord le logline du film donc
c'est ce film ne vous dit pas comment
gagner au loto il vous dit comment
gagner deux fois au loto puisque ce prof
de maths a développé une théorie
soi-disant pour gagner un faiblement au
loto alors ce type là est-il un escroc
ou un génie en tous les cas il vient une
star parce qu'il est pris en main par un
publicitaire absolument insensé
et là s'il y a une façon de gagner au
loto
ça veut dire que c'est plus la peine de
jouer donc le chiffre d'affaires de la
Française des jeux s'effondre l'état
croupier vacille on dit pas l'état
croupion non l'état croupier
et la fille des RG c'est à dire Stein
trouve rien de mieux que confier
l'enquête à son amant le le tricheur le
requin des tapis verts il y a que lui
qui puisse se débrouiller l'histoire
pas mal raconté
ses escroquerie au loto et bon bah
forcément bien sûr qu'il y a une
escroquerie bien sûr qu'il y a pas de
martingale pour gagner de fois de suite
donc et le mec a vraiment gagné deux
fois de suite donc il y a escroquerie et
c'est quoi l'escroquerie moi c'est ça
qui m'a fait tourner les PagesJaunes
Le Retour de Martin gars non avec
Gérard Depardieu je comprends c'est
exact normalement on le coupe au montage
mais là je le couperai pas mal c'est de
l'ami van ce qu'on appelle de la Niva
oui non c'est génial il y a un vrai
Sénart en plus il y a un vrai suspense
c'est c'est très intéressant alors ce
que vous allez faire parce qu'il faut
bien que les gens voient à quoi ça
ressemble vous allez regarder votre
caméra et vous allez dire magnéto
Serge comme ça qu'il faut faire
du Loto un
[Musique]
même par million d'euros je suis parvenu
à démontrer que l'on pouvait dompter le
hasard vous dit il va gagner des
fortunes devant tout le monde ça va
faire rêver la terre entière
cet homme c'est Jacques Loriot et une
dizaine d'années il a fait sauter toutes
les tables de blackjack
souviens de tout en permanence pourquoi
vous nous parlez de ce type
j'ai pas envie de passer du côté des
flics
[Musique]
un joueur compulsif abonné à la mouise
on en est où ce type n'a pas pu tricher
le système de la Française des jeux
était un violeable il a gagné comme une
fois de suite et c'est impossible
absolument
je crois que quelque chose que tu nous
échappé il faut qu'on prenne toute
depuis le début
[Musique]
la probabilité de gagner trois fois de
suite au loto et de 1 sur 2000 milliards
de milliards est un génie c'est un génie
de la manipulation
il s'en fout plein les poches depuis le
début de cette histoire
pour ça que je me dis un truc
super
et Thierry Lhermitte
ce soir voilà sortie le 23 juin voilà
alors vous avez accepté le film parce
que Laurent benedy d'abord avait fait au
petit Marguerite absolument qui est un
film assez sympa déjà hein et puis bon
le Sénat plein de plein d'humour plein
de suspense ouais puis le truc là c'est
ça qui m'a fait tourner les pages moi
vraiment mais comment est-ce qu'un mec
peut tricher pour garant gagnant deux
fois de suite au loto il y a pas de
complicité dans l'étiquette c'est pas un
faux ticket il y a pas de complicité à
la Française des Jeux le tirage voilà
c'est quoi l'astuce alors
elle est pas mal
c'est pour de vrai ça peut exister alors
votre personnage Thierry Lhermitte c'est
à la fois génie un looser c'est un génie
parce qu'il est hypernésique parce que
ça veut dire il a une mémoire incroyable
il y a une super mémoire il se souvient
de tout tous les tirages tous les c'est
très utile pour les pour les cartes dans
les casinos parce qu'évidemment il se
souvient de toutes les cartes qui ont
été
génial et son côté looser c'est qu'il
est accroché au jeu puis que c'est une
maladie hyper amnésie parce que c'est un
salaire marrant de se souvenir de tout
en l'occurrence c'est probablement
invivable je sais pas si ça existe
complètement cette maladie
un petit peu le voilà les femmes sont
comme ça
certaines les femmes se rappellent ça
c'est une vanne québécoise donc c'est
bien
non te laisse pas pourrir par lui non
mais c'est pas la même culture
et donc l'hypermnésie le conduit à avoir
des rapports très calculés avec les
autres
qu'elle me souligne un moment
elles a parce qu'on va se séparer un
moment dans l'histoire et elle me dit le
problème c'est que moi dans quelques
temps ton visage va se passer je
penserai autre chose etc alors que toi
ça risque de durer longtemps voilà c'est
un gros désavantage quand même c'est
terrible dans une histoire d'amour j'ai
une bonne mémoire vous
à l'époque du lycée Pasteur à Neuilly il
était quel boulevard celui-ci pasteur
Inkerman bravo après le lycée après le
lycée vous jouez dans une boîte qui
s'appelle opoto c'était l'adresse
c'était c'était rue de la Banque
le titre juste au milieu bravo
le titre de cette pièce que vous jouiez
au poteau non Georges pas ici bien après
ma tête est malade deux comédiens vous
rejoignent pour aménager le second
splendide rue des Lombards il y a une
fille et un garçon
il y a Josiane Balasko et Bruno moineau
oh là là quelle mémoire quand même
là-dessus
alors en 78 vous rencontrez Hélène ex
mannequin c'est le coup de foudre
adresse du restaurant vous l'avez
rencontré
la rue Saint-Denis bravo
80 vous flashez sur Adjani donc Clara
elle est chic type non du personnage
ah effacer
avant les ripoux vous tournez un petit
September nom de la Major
MGM 86 se sont vos débuts de producteurs
et d'acteurs d'ennuis d'ivresse non du
réalisateur
merde
Bernard Bernard c'est horrible
excuse-moi Bernard
et voilà
comme il est mal sa femme
[Rires]
je crois
alors Thierry Lhermitte prix obtenu par
un Indien dans la ville en 1995 dans la
catégorie Meilleure producteur oui oui
c'était le prix Georges BOURD de
Beauregard
le titre du remake US du Père Noël est
une ordure mix note bravo non des
réalisateur
des Bronzés vous retrouvailles après 20
ans tournage en mai 2005 qu'est-ce qui
me fait le plus plaisir quand vous vous
retrouvez entre vous
validez de redire des conneries là tu
vas pendant toute la journée pendant le
temps qu'on écrit de ouais c'est ça
qu'est-ce qui vous fait pas rire chez
Christian Clavier
je ne sais pas moi
avec super drôle
qu'est-ce qui me fait pas me fait rire
je suis grand client
qu'est-ce qui vous rend pas jaloux chez
Gérard Jugnot
qu'est-ce qui m'empa jalouse je ne sais
pas sa coiffure peut-être
qu'est-ce qui vous séduit le plus
chez Josiane Balasko
qu'est-ce qui séduit le plus dans une
c'est son rire oui oui sans humour sans
rire son intelligence sa joie de vivre
voilà bien qu'est-ce qui manque à Michel
Blanc pour vous séduire
l'hypocrisie au bout d'un moment ça
revient facilement aucun problème bon
alors il y a une autre promo parce que
double promotion ce soir vous savez ça
quand même ouais ok double
l'autre promo on en parlera la semaine
prochaine plus longuement avec Patrick
TIMS et Laurent Deutsch c'est
l'Américain où vous jouez le rôle d'un
avocat froid et cynique qui est de l'eau
en Deutsch à être américain obtenir
nationalité américaine exactement c'est
une idée de cette idée de fou de germer
dans l'idée de Patrick dans la tête de
Patrick Timsit donc c'est Laurent
Deutsch est un mec qui et qui pense
qu'il a le gène américain il pense qu'il
est américain comme les gens qui seront
transexuels qui pensent qu'ils sont nés
dans le mauvais corps voilà voilà
donc il sent qu'il est américain et
voilà je suis l'avocat qui prend le pari
de l'obtenir la nationalité
alors on va regarder le teaser vous
allez recommencer je suis désolé c'est
un petit peu mais bon vous allez
regarder votre caméra et vous allez dire
encore une fois magnéto Serge Serge
magnietto
bonjour je m'appelle Francis Farge du
lotissement des Merlettes et je suis
américain non monsieur vous êtes
français je pense américain alors
je suis américain français
oui bah non ça suffit
pas cheval dans une vallée attaquée par
des sous
est fini ce que j'entends ne me fait pas
plaisir du tout on va faire des efforts
[Musique]
en permanence et au niveau langue au
niveau langue il a les bases mais pas
les bonnes
[Musique]
ticket de pirates ce qui veut dire
l'Américain on en parlera la semaine
prochaine donc avec Patrick Timsit et
Laurent Deutsch vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir beaucoup changé depuis vos
débuts avec le splendide
non mais toi non plus tu n'as pas changé
mais c'est toi qui va répondre aux
questions à faire une interview
changement
[Musique]
dans le regard des filles de 20 ans en
revanche ah oui oui oui
ce qui a changé dans votre façon de
faire l'amour Thierry
expérience ah c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai ce qui a changé dans vos
peurs Thierry Lhermitte
des trucs qui me faisaient pas peur
avant et puis maintenant je suis parti
en bateau pendant un an ça me faisait
pas peur et maintenant l'idée la mère me
fait peur alors j'avais pas peur du tout
c'est vrai que vous avez fait un tour du
monde avec Hélène d'ailleurs et votre
couple a résisté à ce tour du monde ils
ont fait le test du tour du monde en
bateau
qu'est-ce qui a changé dans les
émissions vous êtes invités
qu'il y avait pas avant il y avait pas
les applaudissements et hurlements tout
le temps
[Applaudissements]
je te parle de d'un temps que les moins
de 20 ans peuvent faire connaître j'ai
connu aussi et qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
changé finalement depuis vos débuts avec
le splendide Thierry Lhermitte
l'envie de dire des conneries et le dire
des conneries de pas voilà et pas trop y
croire
est-ce que tu aurais une question à
poser à Thierry Lhermitte oui et bien
pose là maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous préférez le théâtre
le cinéma ou
je vais pas terminé
qu'est-ce qui se passe
aux gens qui n'ont pas assez d'argent
pour voir les deux films ils ont juste
de quoi s'acheter un ticket question
pourri c'est bon peut-être que si
perdent ils achètent le ticket il gagne
au loto ils auront largement de quoi
voir bonne réponse bonne réponse
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu